[Music]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream our 35th
is that correct yep 35th i am here with
dr heather hing as always
and we have so much to talk about
because the world just does not stop
doing its crazy 2020 thing
so we are going to get right to it shall
we start with the unity update
yep all right many people are asking
about unity 2020
unity 2020 is about to go into a
different phase and that phase
is offense i must tell you that i am
looking at
information about how this election is
shaping up and i
never cease to be shocked even though
i'm well aware of the parameters and how
they're all
laid out so what i will tell you is that
we have something
an initiative we are going to debut this
week
probably monday it is for americans
primarily so it will probably be done
monday evening i have to check with the
people i'm interfacing with in order to
make it happen
but this initiative is called campfire
and campfire involves
discussions of the unity 2020 project
in all of its manifestations and what we
should be doing going forward and
hopefully you will join us
for that we have it slated to be
interactive we have built the capacity
to make it interactive
and we will unveil that on our first
campfire and then we will build it out
so it can do more
uh over time but in any case look out
for
um announcements of our first unity
campfire
we also have an animation to debut today
our second animation
zach can you bring it up on the screen
and play it
every four years each american voter has
the privilege and patriotic duty to
decide
who is the lesser evil it's the question
that's been at the heart of our great
democracy for decades
that's why political scientists
developed a machine to assist with that
process
the evil meter intakes data on revolving
door politics influence peddling insider
trading and a host of other parameters
so that every american voter has a clear
and obvious
oh can we get evil meters that go to 11
those do go to 11. hey what is going on
someone get the lights oh come on
you're fighting over this again isn't
there a better way
like what i don't know it just seems
like we're so focused on the lesser part
that we're missing something
oh yeah who the f
needs that machine unity 20 20.
let's try this without the evil
[Music]
all right i'm feeling better already
um yeah lovely animation thank you
harris
um so anyway i think that's it for the
unity update look for the campfires
and we will get down to the business of
how to make this movement
function where should people look for
the campfires uh well you can look for
an announcement certainly on
my twitter feed you can also look for it
at the unity twitter feed
articles of unity and uh we will put a
message
on our website um articlesofunity.org
so there's three places or places you
can go
and the unity youtube channel as well
which is also where you can find this
animation yes you will be able to find
this animation uh
we will upload it but this has been the
debut so it is not up yet
all right well today we have
we've had to cut a lot of things that we
wanted to talk about today some of the
things that i want to talk about today
are uh vaclav havel the personality
traits of people of particular political
ideologies the connections between white
supremacy and biological sex
and aristotle okay okay
okay so uh uh let's start let's start
with
with vaclav havel a a viewer
sent me his essay the power of the
powerless
and uh suggested that my point about
these signs that we're seeing in windows
which i'm calling don't hurt me displays
uh is very much like what he talks about
in the third part of his essay which i'm
going to read today but first let me
just remind viewers of who he is
was he died i don't know 10
years ago something like that he was a
czech playwright and essayist
a political dissident who founded among
other organizations the committee for
the defense of the unjustly prosecuted
and he was a political prisoner for many
years his political party played a
primary role in the velvet revolution
which removed the communists from party
uh from power in czechoslovakia in 1989
and following that hovel was the last
president of czechoslovakia through 1992
and then following the dissolution of
czechoslovakia he was the first
president of the czech republic through
2003.
so he wrote this essay
the the power of the perilous
and the whole thing is worth a read but
here is a
somewhat long excerpt from it
the manager of a fruit and vegetable
shop places in his window
among the onions and carrots the slogan
workers of the world unite
why does he do it what is he trying to
communicate to the world
is he genuinely enthusiastic about the
idea of unity among the workers of the
world
is his enthusiasm so great that he feels
an irrepressible impulse to acquaint the
public with his ideals
has he really given more than a moment's
thought to how such unification
might occur and what it would mean i
think it can safely be assumed that the
overwhelming majority of shopkeepers
never think about the slogans they put
in their windows nor do they use them to
express their real opinions
that poster was delivered to our green
grocer from the enterprise
headquarters along with the onions and
carrots he put them all into the window
simply because it has been done that way
for years because everyone does it and
because that is the way it has to be
if he were to refuse there could be
trouble he could be reproached for not
having the proper decoration at his
window
someone might even accuse him of
disloyalty he does it because these
things must be done if one is to get
along in life
it is one of the thousands of details
that guarantee him a relatively tranquil
life
in harmony with society as they say
obviously the green grocer is
indifferent to the semantic content of
the slogan on exhibit
he does not put the slogan in his window
from any personal desire to acquaint the
public with the ideal it expresses
this of course does not mean that his
action has no motive or significance at
all that the slogan communicates nothing
to anyone
the slogan is really a sign and as such
it can contains a subliminal but very
definite message
verbally it might be expressed this way
i the green grocer
live here and i know what i must do i
behave in the manner expected of me
i can be dependent upon and am beyond
reproach and
i am obedient and therefore i have the
right to be left in peace
this message of course has an address c
it is directed above to the green
grocery superior and at the same time it
is a shield that protects the green
grocer from potential informers
the slogan's real meaning therefore is
rooted firmly in the green grocer's
existence
it reflects his vital interests but what
are those vital interests
let us take note if the green grocer had
been instructed to display the slogan i
am afraid and therefore unquestioningly
obedient
he would not be nearly as indifferent to
its semantics
even though the statement would reflect
the truth the green grocer would be
embarrassed and ashamed to put such an
unequivocal statement of his own
degradation in the shop window and quite
naturally so for he is a human being and
thus has a sense of his own dignity
to overcome this complication his
expression of loyalty must take the form
of a sign which
at least on his textual surface
indicates a level of disinterested
conviction it must allow the green
grocer to say
what's wrong with the workers of the
world uniting
thus the sign helps the green grocer to
can feel from to conceal from himself
the low foundations of his obedience
at the same time concealing the low
foundations of power
it hides them behind the facade of
something high and that something
is ideology ideology is a specious way
of relating to the world
it offers human beings the illusion of
an identity and of dignity and of
morality while making it easier for them
to part with them
as the repository of something super
personal and objective it enables people
to deceive their conscience and conceal
their true position and their inglorious
modis vivendi
both from the world and from themselves
it is a very pragmatic but
at the same time an apparently dignified
way of legitimizing what is above
below and on either side it is directed
toward people and toward god
it is a veil behind which human beings
can hide their own fallen existence
their trivialization and their
adaptation to the status quo
it is an excuse that everyone can use
from the green grocer who conceals his
fear of losing his job behind an alleged
interest in the unification of the
workers of the world
to the highest functionary whose
interest in staying in power can be
cloaked in phrases about service to the
working class
the primary excusatory function of
ideology therefore
is to provide people both as victims and
pillars of the post totalitarian system
with the illusion that the system is in
harmony with the human order and the
order of the universe
the smaller a dictatorship and the less
stratified by modernization the society
under it
the more directly the will of the
dictator can be exercised
in other words the dictator can employ
more or less naked discipline
avoiding the complex processes of
relating to the world and of
self-justification which ideology
involves
but the more complex the mechanisms of
power become the larger and more
stratified the society they embrace
and the longer they have operated
historically
the more individuals must be connected
to them from outside and the greater the
importance attached to the ideological
excuse
it acts as a kind of bridge between the
regime and the people
across which the regime approaches the
people and the people approach the
regime
this explains why ideology plays such an
important role in the post-totalitarian
system
that complex machinery of units
hierarchies transmission belts
and indirect instruments of manipulation
which ensure in countless ways the
integrity of the regime
leaving nothing to chance would be quite
simply unthinkable without ideology
acting as its all-embracing excuse
and as the excuse for each of its parts
so he's writing about the state of
course
and the way that the will of the state
is exercised by
apparently free actions by people who
are
he is pointing out of course not free at
all and
while there are certainly state excesses
in every state and right now for us
most of what we have been talking about
here has been the excesses of the new
ideology the new religion and john
mcwhorter's framing
that is coming from the the pseudo left
the far left
uh and it is exactly the same tactics
yeah i'm i'm not actually sure that it's
different in any regard in other words
only that it's not the state well yet
it's becoming the state
it's becoming the state or it is
threatening to become the state
very quickly and this is the thing that
uh is so frightening to those of us who
are watching this train wreck
unfold in slow motion is that we have
a cynical political party toying with
this ideology
basically uh imagining falsely
that it can use this ideology to its own
ends which you and i have seen
unfold exactly at evergreen this is
exactly what experience explained george
bridges
uh empowering this movement three years
ago
and it dismantled the college and the
college
has not recovered it is continuing to
double down as of
this most recent week on these same
ideas um i i
learned of there are these things called
institutes which you know
some are institutes that evergreen are
little meetings on topics that occur
during the summer that
faculty participate in and there was
apparently one
done remotely this year because of covid
in which
the assembled faculty were apparently
enamored of the idea
that they should put up memorials to the
protesters from 2017
which is just staggering in light of the
spectacular decline the college has
taken
as a result of the action of these
people and their
faculty instigators so that's uh that's
exactly analogous to yes what hovel is
talking about here
and the signs and windows and the
uh now ritual repeating of we are on the
stolen lands of the people who came
before us
at the beginning of for instance live
theater in many places
um but also what happened at yale uh
with uh the christakisses
uh where the chief instigator of the
protests that became much more than
protests against nicolas christakis
ended up being uh awarded the
the award by yale and i don't remember
exactly what it was called but it was
basically the award
uh for contributing the most to easing
racial tensions on campus i can't even
say it with a straight face
right so uh yes let's let's erect a
monument
to the protesters at evergreen on the
evergreen campus and uh what will those
who come after what were the
archaeologists of the college who could
start acting there pretty quickly
depending on how quickly it falls uh
what will what will they think of that
right well what will they think of that
indeed and i i should say this is uh
obviously not unprecedented in this case
because evergreen also took the
lead protester who became a writer and
kidnapper jameel
and put him on the committee to rewrite
the student code of conduct they
actually paid him
to help rewrite the student code of
conduct so anyway everything is on its
head
um i'm reminded there's a scene in
catch-22
in which uh a squadron has
i believed dumped their bombs over the
ocean
in order not to fly over enemy territory
and in order to hide this embarrassment
they are given
medals for their bravery or something
like this
yes right anyway joseph heller saw this
stuff
in a military context no and actually
that
catch-22 should be on the list of books
along with brave new world
and 1984 an animal farm for sure
absolutely yeah
um all right anything else you want to
say about
uh the extended the green grocer hovel's
green grocer and
i don't remember which episode it was i
forgot to go back and look but
several episodes ago i showed several
pictures that i just taken in a
neighborhood in southwest portland
uh that morning showing how many
businesses
are you know i said then feeling
compelled putting up these don't
don't hurt me displays of you know from
as simple as just the black lives matter
to you know
all manner of further ideological
support beyond that uh and uh i i don't
think that almost
anyone who's doing it is doing it
actually under their own volition no
matter what they would tell you
no they rationalize it later but that's
not where it comes from and that's and
that's the brilliance of you know how
hubble lived this right now so i do have
two things to say
one is i'm pretty sure i i would have
found
what he said interesting before the
current era but i wouldn't have
understood it
right watching you know as i ride my
bike around and things like this and i
note where
you know whose lawn is announcing it's
uh it's
black lives and you know which theaters
are broadcasting it on their marquees
and all of this
you know i have this sort of odd sense
of like what's actually going on and
that
explains it exactly i will also say that
i am now seeing online and in
my personal life um people from the
former czechoslovakia
who are attempting to reach us americans
with a very important message
and i don't think they have it perfectly
right which is bad because it means it's
going to be harder for the
massive part that is right to get
through but their point is look
we saw this we saw this exact thing and
it preceded something that you do not
know is coming because people and in
fact somebody said it to me just today
on
the patreon discussion that we just
finished they said
up until the moment that the shooting
started people were telling themselves
it couldn't happen here cooler heads
will prevail and
so anyway i think the problem is that
the
antagonist is not identical and so it is
going to be easier to dismiss that
warning
than it should be and and it never is
right
and of course you know to there will be
some similarities no matter
how dis dissimilar the situation there
will be some dissimilarities no matter
how similar
and the trick is figuring out which of
these which of the things that might be
similar or dissimilar are actually
predictive of what happens next
and what we are saying is that el nino
hovel has this
very precise level of prediction here
around
signage popping up um you know he
doesn't actually specify
you know it being all of a sudden um but
to me the all of a suddenness
of it you know and and the black lives
matter signage actually showed up all of
a sudden and became this
this sign of fealty on campus at
evergreen and i know
elsewhere on other campuses well back in
probably 2016
actually this was this was before but
now right now
um this is on this is on more lawns this
is on more storefronts
and um yeah let's maybe
maybe that for now that one one last
thing benjamin boyce came up with
episode 22 of the complete evergreen
story and it
revealed tape from a class that he had
been in his final evergreen
class uh when he was a student which
the recording is from after the protests
and riots had begun at evergreen
and it involves a struggle session which
just like the match is not exact for
uh czechoslovakia um the
match is um close to now
it's close to mao except with a twist
you know the professor is in on the
struggle section and it is a student
being
humiliated um but anyway it is well
worth a listen
um and anyway i will have more to say on
it in the future but it
you probably if you're looking for
things to to look into that would be a
a good one to understand what things
sounded like in a class
as the nonsense unfolded yeah i guess
one more thing with regard to
contemporary or close to contemporary uh
movements and historical moments that
have looked like this and from which we
should be learning
um you say you've been hearing from
people from czech republic
um we've also been seeing uh
people talk about similarities to what's
been going on in venezuela
and you know we have we have spoken with
some refugees from venezuela the last
time we were in ecuador
well not the last time actually when we
were in ecuador with our class in
2016 who had you know these these
highly educated professionals who had to
flee um who told
who told quite remarkable stories which
maybe we'll share at some point
and then i think on an episode upcoming
at some point we may
talk about similarities between what's
going on now in america and what's been
going on in chile
very recently because i've i've received
some communications about that that
uh basically says i'm writing from the
future i in chile i'm running from the
future and it's the near
future and it's your future if you guys
don't see this
your future in the world's one
superpower which adds another layer to
this because
if we destabilize ourselves that would
be stupid from the point of view of our
well-being but the amount that the world
has writing on it is
uh huge yeah all right well let's um
let's talk about uh a paper that was
published
uh this mo uh last month i guess now
it's august now so july 18
2020 it's called the dark triad traits
predict authoritarian political
correctness and alt-right attitudes
uh by jordan moss and peter o'connor one
of the authors um
forwarded it to us so that's how i come
to know about it uh and let me just uh
discuss briefly what it what it finds
uh it's brand new there hasn't been i
expect that there will be pushback
um there hasn't been any that i've seen
yet um and i don't see anything in my
uh admittedly not super in-depth read of
it but i did
i did read the paper in its entirety uh
the background
uh is that we know that personality
traits are associated with a range of
political attitudes and behaviors these
include there
are several examples of this well well
vetted in in the literature
that people who are on the left tend to
be more open to experience
and identify as being more open to
experience and people on the right
tend to have uh tend to be more
conscientious
so that's just just two and you know
there is there is no value judgment in
me saying that this is just a result
from
many replicated uh basically psychology
uh research uh endeavors uh that find
that this is true
so this particular study uh this mason
o'connor 2020 study
looked at the distribution of four
traits uh those being entitlement
and then the three so-called dark triad
traits which are machiavellianism
narcissism and psychopathy so they
looked at the distribution of those four
traits
in three groups and the three groups
that they looked at
are one far-right group basically white
identitarianism
and what many people would just think of
as alt-right like actual alt-right not
the mass
number of of us who are sometimes called
that because they're trying to get rid
of us or something
and then two groups on the far left so
they
i think the thing that's really new here
is that they split uh the far left into
two groups what they call
political correctness authoritarianism
and political correctness liberalism
and they say that in each of these three
cases and i'll define these in a minute
but in each of these three cases
they um they are a very small but
extremely
vocal and uh unduly powerful
uh voice in what is happening in
politics right now
so with regard to the two far-right
groups normally which get lumped
together
they say that political correctness
authoritarians the pcas
espouse beliefs for for instance in the
need for violence to achieve goals
and uh the plural correctness liberalism
group tends to speak in terms of
compassion
and now they don't do this but i feel
like uh
this neatly maps on to sort of malcolm x
versus martin luther king
um that the the the black panthers saw
the need for violence to achieve goals
and were very uh very vocal about it and
uh martin luther king and his adherents
uh spoke much more in terms of in terms
of compassion and did not speak to the
need for violence
so we have these these three groups um
that this study
is um looking at in the form of i think
they looked at
something between five and 600 americans
um
who from uh from from questionnaires
the authors slotted into either
political correctness authoritarians
political correctness liberals or white
identitarians
and then they assess through other
well-known psychological measures
whether or not they tended to show
relatively high
forms of any of these four personality
measures entitlement
machiavellianism narcissism and
psychopathy
and the result in short is that while
the political correctness
liberals did not show particularly high
levels of any of these
both the white identitarians the
so-called alt-right
and the political correctness
authoritarians what has sometimes been
called the control left but specifically
the authoritarian control left
showed scored much higher in psychopathy
and entitlement
than do the political correctness
liberals or
presumably background levels in the
population but not narcissism and
machiavellianism but not narcissism and
machiavelli is a
machiavellianism yeah that's interesting
because i would have thought um
narcissism and machiavellianism would be
rolled into psychopathy
yeah so you know this this we could get
into and i would have to do
more review of what all the measures are
you know the dark the three dark triad
traits are sometimes lumped precisely
because they can be
hard to distinguish from one another and
some argue
that they really shouldn't be
distinguished but using the measures
that these authors used
which do distinguish them they found
higher levels of entitlement and
psychopathy
in both the authoritarian left and the
authoritarian right but not the
basically the pc
liberals and i i don't love the word
liberals there but you know there it is
um who are you know who may well be the
people putting the signs in their yards
and on their storefronts
and arguing that we do need a kind of
you know aggressive affirmative action
that
prevents people who used to have power
from um retaining any power in the
future you know all of which
i disagree with but that those people do
seem to be driven
uh by different personality traits it
does not seem to be about entitlement or
about um
psychopathy whereas there are higher
levels of psychopathy entitlement
in both the authority and left and right
yeah now
two things one i think the
the thing that is most under described
in this whole process is the
rationalization that takes people who
may be motivated by something like fear
and um causes them to act
based on their compassion in other words
their compassion gets hijacked
and they become part of the problem by
virtue of the fact that they are trying
to address
a fear that is frankly legitimate and
understandable but the way they do it
externalizes the danger onto onto other
people so i hear you
basically predicting that the political
correctness liberals
are more likely to become political
correctness authoritarians
with perhaps greater exposure to the
political correctness authoritarians or
as this just
appears to grow in power and and does
actually grow in power
oh there's that i mean is that yeah is
that the prediction it's not that they
become authoritarians but they become
the pawns of the authoritarians and you
hear this in their language so early on
uh back you know 2017-ish there was this
thing
of course you're an ally to black people
right well sure who wouldn't be
right ah well here's what ally means it
means accomplice
oh okay well now you've just signed up
for a willingness to
break the law um okay what is
you know what does that mean well it
means that you
are to um do the bidding you're to do
what you're told
you are to advance the cause you are to
stand between the law
and the black people and so the point is
you have now been
captured by virtue of your own desire
to actually deal with a real risk
you know it's not necessarily the people
who feel that risk
who are doing it but the point is it is
your compassion for people
uh that causes you to do the bidding of
others
and then you look like uh an
um an authoritarian because basically
the point is authoritarians have got
your strings
now i did want to say you draw an
interesting distinction between malcolm
x
and martin luther king where you put
martin luther king like i said that's
not that's not in the paper that's my
mapping on to what they've
what they've done my concern about it is
that i don't see
anything in what i understand of malcolm
x that i would describe
as psychopathic in other words i think
he was
definitely militant but the point is
there was also a selflessness to his
militants
right i think he knew he was going to
end up paying
the ultimate price for it which does not
strike me as something
a psychopath would do i also don't think
martin luther king was politically
correct
right so i mean i don't i don't think
it's a match in terms of the descriptors
of
you know in terms of a lot of what is
going on here but in terms of if we're
if we're trying to draw a distinction
between
the movement that is happening that is
revealing itself in probably your office
and on the streets right now in very
different ways uh between these two
between these two manifestations um we
have
a a part of the movement can be driven
by compassion or one that
feels that violence is uh the only way
to go and that that is a decent decent
match
we have cat bell in the background yes
now when you say in your office you're
not talking about my office because we
are
we're currently in my house in your
office yeah if it's happening is it on
this side of the room or that side
i don't it might supposed to be on the
cat side that actually that fits for me
yeah
okay yep um all right uh
oh you wanted to segue from that before
i talk about uh yeah white supremacism
i wanted to say you know we spent a lot
of time in the last couple of live
streams talking about the confusion that
the world seems to have about what's
going on in portland
and um the portland
rioters won a huge victory which is that
they
managed to invert cause and effect but
they got
an important photo op out of it which is
that the state
negotiated to have the federal
government withdraw
its officers now they're withdrawing
them
under the agreement that the state will
enforce the law which if the state had
done in the first place to federal
officers wouldn't have been necessary so
the the idea
that you know we have driven out the
feds and you know
law order is now going to be managed by
one
we've agreed to do what we should have
been doing two months ago right and so
how is that a win for you this doesn't
fit with the idea that the feds are
fascists who came here to beat people up
because why would they have agreed to
leave and
it doesn't fit anything about the uh the
chronology
but well i mean i i
i can see i i don't believe that but i
can see
that uh they came and they were
interested in beating people up
being consistent with a they were sent
in order to solve a problem by someone
by by that was seen by someone else well
like i don't i don't believe this
but i don't think that's an inconsistent
interpretation no no
what i think is the local
rioters managed to um
get the local authorities not to enforce
the law leaving the only law
and the only relevant law given that
they were attacking federal buildings
as federal officers there needed to be
an influx
i don't i'm not going to defend how they
behaved you need more legal expertise
than we have to even evaluate whether or
not
that made sense or not but it certainly
made sense that you would have to
send federal officers to repel these
nightly
riots and the fact that those officers
are now leaving
is not evidence of anything other than
the state having agreed to do its job
however
it does open the possibility were this a
well-disciplined movement
that the movement would now become uh
very
careful to halt the violence which
preceded the federal officers
arriving here because then that would
foster their story that they had been
reacting to an attack by the feds
but instead the narcissism of this
movement
is resulting in it suddenly having
no reason for being because the reason
for the world's attention is reduced if
there's not tear gas being fired at them
and there's no reason to fire
tear gas if they're not behaving
violently well maybe so just just to get
back to that last paper maybe it's not
the narcissism of the movement but the
combination of entitlement psychology
and psychopathy yes
um but one of the things they did which
i found
totally shocking um was hey zach can you
put up the video
right yep so this
is a display out in front of
i believe the justice center and this is
the severed head this is from when this
is from good
lord yes this is uh recently this is
since
since there's thursday or later since
the fed's pulled out um
and you can see it appears to be the
severed head of a pig
i believe it is real they have placed a
police cap a local police cap on it
or at least that's the way it's been
reported they placed it on an american
flag and they set it on fire
right so the obvious implication this is
an obvious threat of violence
against the local police right who are
the reason that the federal police are
now willing to withdraw
so these people are now being threatened
clearly with death if you
read and not very deeply into this and
it also suggests something you know i
can't say for sure
that they didn't source the head of a
pig from a butcher
and that this is all symbolic but
there's actually reason to think
that they may have killed the animal
because there are two prior incidents
so zach can you show the picture of the
uh
the head next to the statue
no that one so this is a prior incident
in which
a severed pig's head was placed at the
base of
what was once the elk statue which was
then
burned and removed um and then
there's so much beauty in this movement
don't you find right and then here
in a prior incident a pig was found
wandering
downtown this is a live pig who's been
blanketed
yeah somebody's put a blanket over it
and the police rescued this pig and the
interpretation
was apparently that protesters had
intended to kill it ritually
um as part of their protest and i think
but we don't know that that's true i
mean it's also i think
the first time that a pig has been found
wandering downtown so it's clearly
somehow related or that is the
clearly the most parsimonious
explanation is that it is related to the
protests right
that's all i'm saying is there's
something wrong
with a person who is trafficking in the
heads of
animals in this casual way and in the
same way that i think
we are rightly frightened by
the child who cultivates their own
indifference to suffering by torturing
animals i think there's something about
the choice of symbolism here
this is no longer graffiti of pigs heads
with their eyes crossed out which is
disturbing enough
in light of the fact that it subscribes
to this all cops or bastards and
can you put up the uh the graffiti on
the windows zach
yes okay there's a picture here so
dead feds i think the point is look the
message here
and when is this from uh before they
rolled out before they pulled out i i
don't know it was posted this week
but my point is the the movement is
trafficking in the idea
of justified lethal violence against
all police you don't need to know which
police you are violent against they all
deserve it
and death is fine and we are going to
use
dead animals to symbolize our commitment
to this idea we are going to place it on
an american flag
the whole thing suggests a depth of
lunacy and disconnection from reality
that is
extreme and it could just be a few
people however
where exactly are the people in this
movement who say whoa
that does not speak for me right yeah
well i do wonder
again to this to this uh moss and
o'connor paper that i was talking about
earlier which i'll post a link to
um if they're right
that there really are two different
camps and that is that maps on to
our understanding of there are a few
what we've just been calling bad actors
for lack of more precision and they're a
bunch of allies and
and some of those are front sitters and
some aren't but they're willing to do
the dirty
work often of um of the bad actors and
at least they're certainly willing to
put signs up and
and vote for mandatory diversity
trainings and all of this but it does
suggest that there is um
that as we move forward as we try to
figure out how to
fight this ideology and um make it less
palatable to people
because it is divisive and dangerous
that is just
true um that there will be different
strategies that will work with these two
groups
for sure and um this you know this is
something we've been saying
for a long time that basically the
people who
um are the bad actors who who do have
high levels of entitlement and
psychopathy
are going to be very hard to be to
reason with and you know when people ask
us i like you know i lost my friend
group
and sometimes our answer has been like
well if they're gone they're gone you'll
make better friends and i don't like
that answer i know it
never pleases me um to the degree that
any of them are in that high psychopathy
and entitlement group
seriously make better friends but to the
degree that
they are in the much larger but still
dangerous of succumbing to ideology
group
that tends to think in terms of
compassion and tends to think that what
they're advocating for is compassionate
we need a different kind of language and
basically offense
which involves something like actually
what you're doing is the opposite of
compassion
this is not going to be helpful for the
people that you claim to be trying to
help
this is not going to help rise raise um
historically oppressed people
out of oppression this is going to
divide and
um and destroy um
well last time i introduced two concepts
that i thought were important for
understanding how this thing functions
and one of them
was verificationism and unfortunately we
don't have time to get to the example
this
this time but uh the verificationism
lens turns out to be super revealing
um and you can just watch it unfold for
anybody who's willing to
speak off the cuff about what they're
thinking and the other one was
autoimmunity
that we are attacking the very things on
which we depend we're being induced to
and i wanted to introduce a third i
increasingly think
that we are watching something that is
i believe literally a group
psychosis and i believe these things are
actually
present in history you know the one
surrounding uh witches in salem for
example
looks like psychosis and it's possible
there's one hypothesis that
actually it was the result of wheat that
had begun to grow air gut fungus which
is basically a hallucinogen it's the
backbone of the
lsd molecule and you can imagine in a
world where
things have cut loose because your mind
is suffering from a
neurotransmitter that triggers unreal
kinds of things to be
commonplace that people could talk
themselves into a belief system about
what was who was causing it and how to
deal with it and all of that
so i think we are seeing the same the
same phenomenon yes
and uh that it is worth thinking about
and the question about what do you do if
your
friends are if you're losing friends to
this if you think in terms of
you are losing your friends to a
psychosis into which they are being
drawn
it in part explains the you know frankly
i think it is callousness that i
i advance in response which is it's not
that
there's nothing tragic about their loss
the question is what can you do about it
and um so this is losing friends to
psychosis losing friends to
a cult tough love is there is the right
move in that in that case and sometimes
that involves saying you know what and
we're done
well if you have six other friends who
are watching somebody drawn into the
psychosis
you can stage some kind of an
intervention yeah but if it's you
and you've lost six friends to the
psychosis you're very unlikely
to be able to reach them and so i mean
you do you know if
in in a situation absent context
if you have seven people to use your
example and
one person sees things very differently
from everyone else
it's possible they're missing what
everyone else can see and
absent every other bit of context all
else being equal that is more likely
just from a parsimony perspective but
uh this is a kind of scales falling from
the eyes thing where once
once you see uh this this way and you
can start
and you can start understanding a lot of
other things that you are seeing
in from this perspective and start
predicting where else it might show up
in the world and from whom else you
might be
um seeing this and you know would when
our inboxes look the way they do and we
are seeing appeals and you know
apologies to the many many people we're
just
not responding to um who are saying
you know my my workplace my theater
company
my museum my um county fair
my everything is falling prey to this
and i'm watching people stop making
sense and they are being less kind
and less good to one another and this
doesn't end well
yeah um so i don't know what to make
of the psychosis angle but it's one of
these things where
you test a new concept and then you just
start looking at new data things you
haven't encountered before and say how
well does it match and unfortunately
this one matches really well it fits as
well i think as the verificationism
and the autoimmunity yeah and so it also
it does say something about what genre
of solution we ought to be looking for
and maybe that's the the silver lining
is that as as bleak as it is to watch
some large percentage
of the population fall into a group
psychosis
the point is the the thing to do the
thing you must not do
even if you have to do it in the moment
is not to humor it with other people
right you can't steal man psychosis
right
um well it's possible we should come
back
to this and really make the point
cleanly with regard to these
um three all in one place
verificationism autoimmunity and
psychosis and group psychosis as
um three perhaps pivotal hallmarks of
this movement
good should we move on let's do it yeah
this will be easy
no it won't um we are told
in this article published on july 28
2020.
um here's zach if you want to show uh
this article
briefly uh jk rowling and the white
supremacist history of biological sex
this article um tells us
it's going to be speaking too uh so did
you did you show it and i've taken it
down now zach
okay good um a quotation this is so a
friend of uh an online friend of mine a
person who is trans
uh forwarded this to me and said would
you please please please please
take uh address this in your next live
stream
uh and so and so we are gonna do it just
very briefly you haven't read the piece
but you can imagine what's in there
um so i'm gonna i'm gonna have a couple
of quotes here certainly has a
tantalizing title oh
so tantalizing jk rowling in the white
supremacist history of biological sex
um so one quotation from it is as many
people are engaging in conversations
about how white supremacy has shaped so
many of our political and social
institutions there is no better time
than the present
to talk about how biological sex and
sexual difference were created
or created over time to protect promote
and police the boundaries of whiteness
that is a quotation created biological
sex was created over time to protect
promote and police the boundaries of
whiteness
um boy this article is
crackbot mess it's a crackpot mess of
misunderstandings about evolutionary
theory again
always right always and illogical
conflations
i'm gonna let's deal with a couple of
them it conflates the veracity of an
idea
with the wrong thing of people who've
stood near that idea it's a classic bait
and switch move right
um and it it happens all the time in
evolution
you know people misunderstand or want to
appropriate a bad understanding of
evolutionary thinking
and claim it as their own and conclude
stupid illogical racist sexist whatever
it is conclusions
and then people who want therefore to
believe that anything evolutionary is
racist sexist whatever
say aha those people over there they
said that they're doing what you're
doing
to which we could say but they're not
they're wrong they're confused they're
bad
like that's not what they're doing um
that the fact that stupid people or
wrong-minded people
stand next to ideas doesn't make those
adjacent ideas wrong like
this just seems so obvious and yet we
deal with this all the time
um okay so here's a quote from the
article
darwin and his followers argued that all
human peoples were related but it was
said that different races were on
different scales or stages
all human beings were now to be viewed
and judged as being on a racialized
continuum where intelligence beauty
immorality fecundity and physical
ability increased
as one moved up evolutionary stages of
course the white europeans who
formulated these theories considered
themselves the most advanced
so that's some 19th century [ __ ]
misunderstanding of what darwin said and
it's not what evolutionary biology is
it's not how evolution works it's not
about stages it's not about hierarchies
well i want to push back just slightly
there is a hierarchy
in paleontology that describes a
move from basically familial units
up through civilization you know so um
before you get to
uh a tribal system you get to uh uh in
anthropology you mean then
yeah paleoanthropology oh okay okay um
that you have a uh a head man system
anyway there is a progression there's
hierarchy within populations for sure
right and within
yes this was understood in
darwin's time by darwin in other words
there is some stuff that you have to
read
in the context of the the level of
understanding that existed
uh when darwin was writing on the other
hand there was also
a awareness that is now caricatured out
of existence
that even to the extent that there was
some sort of understanding that
uh hunter-gatherers were in some way
primitive
there was no sense that that inherently
meant
that they weren't headed towards
civilization and finding themselves in a
different stage
so anyway i don't want to dwell
uh in the 19th century right in order to
sort it out
that's the big flaw here right yeah but
anyway the point is look
you know you could do a sober analysis
here of what they had right and what
they had wrong and what
persists and what doesn't and all of
that
or you can go verification we're not
arguing
that uh all people are equivalent
or all cultures are equivalent or as
good at doing everything that other
cultures are doing nope
that's not true not true at all and
there are those who would argue that
and therefore our claim that some some
people in some cultures are better
at doing some things than other people
in other cultures are doing would claim
that that in itself was the same thing
as this racist garbage when it's not
right um and in fact
okay so another just one other thing
this article does
um it discusses actually discusses an
idea again from 19th century
race garbage that i hadn't even heard
before i thought i'd heard all the
stupid things that emerged from
supposedly you know
evolutionary thinking but apparently
high degrees of sexual dimorphism in
humans was
supposed to be an indicator of a more
evolved race
which is so and the person writing the
article doesn't know what they're doing
they're completely clueless
um and so they actually seem to claim
the opposite but you go look at the link
and it's like oh okay
so you know these these people in the
19th century who were trying to use
science to justify their racist
conclusions
came up with this they found that um you
know european they
they found evidence that europeans had
more sexual dimorphism than men and
women are more different in europeans
than other races uh today we're talking
about
um uh indicators that just all
across the board it seems not just not
just height i don't think
um but it's
again the fact that there have been
confused racists who spin their
fantasies in the language of science
does not make the science racist right
the fact that you have an
idea that is taken and used to some and
that is not okay does not make the idea
itself not okay
those aren't the same thing so
again the whole article is this actually
what i've written here is it's a
verificationist mess
it is it is that it's a verificationist
mess of motivated reasoning and sloppy
thinking
but it's also true so i
i kind of threw up my hands like this
this is some let's see what is he the
author of this article
is a phd candidate in political science
and also a student in feminist studies
um so he can't get it right that's
higher ed for you at the moment um
that's that's terrible and we've talked
about that a lot
um but i wanted to actually just use
this as a
segue to quickly say something about
again that even scientists
are hiding behind this kind of of logic
now and some of them actually seem to
believe it so a friend of a
friend a biologist friend recently
shared his
biologist friend's claim uh that
everything is a social construct
and this this guy this former i think
friend of a friend
literally uses the fact that there is no
single definition of species
that works for all species to then claim
that both math and sex are social
constructs
so just i'm gonna repeat that because
there is no single definition of species
that works for all species
the unspoken connector here is all
biological constructs
categories are the same therefore math
is a social construct and sex is such a
construct and gender is a social
construct and everything's a social
construct
so i i responded to my friend who shared
this this guy's a biologist are you
kidding me
like to conflate the lack of universal
species concept
with the lack of any formal you know
firmly definable categories in the world
is to abandon the idea of an objective
universe
like he this guy doesn't get to call
himself a scientist actually
like i i wish sometimes i wish i could
be king for the day
and take all of these phds away from
people
because this is such a serious
failure of of logic and if you are
actually claiming to be a biologist
who thinks who has looked at all at
diversity
of species and decided that
the lack of a universal species concept
is mappable onto there is no sex
that's ridiculous you and i used to face
students you used to meet students
who came from totally crap k-12
educations who somehow have been
totally totally confused by creationist
households
and within weeks of meeting these 18
year olds we would disabuse them of this
nonsense
and now we have phds in the sciences who
are arguing this
it's insane i don't i don't think this
guy would recognize a phylogeny if it
hit him upside the head and i'd kind of
like to see it do it
watch one of these trees falling exactly
so at some level
it's such witness and cowardice it's
insane if you think
that sex is a social construct you're
doing it wrong
same goes for math
yeah good good good good i like that
that was good so that was good yes
um are you are you where you wanted to
go with this sure i mean i could go off
for a long time well i just know what
i'm gonna talk good
i want to point out that actually all
three of the characteristics that we've
been playing with yes
sit here you've got the verificationism
you're going to go through science and
you're going to find something like
uh species ambiguity which is real
and assume that that means ambiguity is
the same for every other category
that's verificationism you have
autoimmunity
where we are attacking the ability to
make sense right if you attack
science by basically taking any
conclusion that it would render and
putting it in the same category as
something problematic like species
then you are basically making it
impossible to establish anything
um and then there's psychosis right this
uh yeah well this if you think about
what it is like if you've ever
encountered a psychotic right
there is a belief
of a malevolent force that is attempting
to manipulate and endanger and there is
license you can categorize it's all cops
right it's the cops right they are the
bad thing
and in this case right there is a
you know do you know what uh sex
is sex is a weapon of white supremacy
right that doesn't sound paranoid as
[ __ ] to you
because it does to me right that sounds
like the government is sending me
messages through the fillings in my
teeth
you know and exactly right it's that
level of nonsense it was the claim that
it
is uh created the concepts of biological
sex and sexual defense were created
over time to protect promote and police
the boundaries of whiteness
right like 500 million years ago guys
well let's put it this way
you can even just test that
scientifically right you could just
simply go
to hunter-gatherers non-white
people and test the question of whether
or not
they believe you don't even have to ask
them what they believe you can just
simply look
at pairings right who pairs off with
whom
right they know that sex exists whether
they use the same terminology for it
that we do or not and you can establish
science when it's homosexual pairings
which does happen
um in every culture known do they make
babies
no they don't no sex was not created
for white supremacy or do they expect to
right they know that those pairings
don't
produce babies so the point is you could
test it scientifically uh what's the
next move
that scientific concept you are using to
establish that this is not
a tool of white supremacy is itself
white supremacy so of course it would
conclude that
right so the point is okay right exactly
it's a hermetically it's a hermetically
sealed
psychotic box into which they want
us all to go to go right hmm what could
possibly go wrong what could possibly go
wrong
yeah so um i will want to finish um by
talking a little bit about
aristotle but maybe you have something
that you want to go to before
before then we're at close to an hour
probably at this point
55 minutes well i wanted to say
something
uh about uh kovid and what i've
learned about something but i think
maybe we should hold that off the next
time if we've only got five minutes
okay um but uh we will do it we got a
lot of coded stuff yeah
all right um so uh in the beginning of
these live streams back in march and
april we made a point of always either
beginning or ending with corrections
and we haven't been doing that as much
lately for one thing
our discussions that were so covet 19
heavy early on there was you know there
was stuff that we just got wrong and
there was stuff that had
changed um and so it was really
important to correct the record very
quickly as as we always did in our
classrooms right we would
um you know what no i'm just thinking
you know the comparison between the sort
of detailed
inner workings of a viral uh particle as
it invades a cell there's a lot of room
to just be simply wrong there yeah
as compared to um sex is an invention of
white people to oppress others
you know it's pretty easy to be on the
right side of that issue if you just
maintain an ability to think yeah which
seems like
people are having a harder and harder
time doing that well that's part of why
they've
they've come here not to join a
community of people that retains
retain and want to retain the ability to
think yeah we
we thank you that you're here um so well
one thing before i get to the the main
correction
is uh we talked about gosh again i think
it was the last episode maybe that was
episode before that
uh the upside down flag that was being
flown outside the federal court
courthouse and we heard from a lot of
people um that it's not inherently an
anti-patriotic statement against the
country whose flag it is
but that is an indication of a country
in distress or
disarray and a number of other i think
it's a nautical thing that flying a flag
upside down is a universal symbol for
distress i i heard
i heard a number of different original
stories and i honestly did not go into
the history
so i think nautical you know may be the
original origin story it may just it may
be convergence i don't know
but that it's not in it is not
inherently an anti-patriotic
move is what i heard from people yeah
which we said we said that you could
read
various things into it and then this
puts a different spin on it yeah
but the but the main correction um that
i want to make is
that as i discussed uh naseem tuleb's
concept of retrospective bigoteering
in i think it was episode 33. uh
and uh i i still i think this is a
concept that is
well worthy of discussion and of talking
about the idea being
uh that applying today's moral standards
uh to people from an earlier time
is uh and you know basically calling
calling earlier people bigots because
they didn't ascribe to the same beliefs
that we are expected to
ascribe to today um is in his framing a
retrospective bigoteering and uh it
makes
it it makes it makes no good sense right
uh and he
i used his recent tweet on the matter
as uh as a jumping off point and he
specifically
talked about this if you want to put
this on the screen just for a minute
zach
he talked about this op-ed should we
cancel aristotle
um by a agnes callard
a philosopher and professor at
university of chicago okay you want to
take that down
um and um
the concept retrospective bigoteering is
absolutely an important one
but this op-ed is exactly the opposite
and uh so i want to correct the record
maybe on behalf of tele as well
but also to say to read a little bit
from this op-ed
and to note just how much dr callard
is is on the side of
careful thinking and logic and
compassion here so your point if i get
it correctly
is that tuleb misdiagnosed this article
and that the article
and teleb's point are in the same
direction exactly
exactly so just an excerpt from
callard's excellent excellent op-ed
which again
is which is called should we cancel
aristotle
which her answer is no uh quote what
makes speech truly free
is the possibility of disagreement
without enmity and this is less a matter
of what we can say than how we can say
it
cancel culture is merely the logical
extension of what we might call
messaging culture
in which every speech act is classified
as friend or foe in which literal
content can barely be communicated
and in which very little faith exists as
to the rational faculties of those being
spoken to
in such a context even the cry for free
speech invites a non-literal
interpretation
as being nothing but the most efficient
way for its advocates to acquire or
consolidate power
i will admit that aristotle's vast
temporal distance from us makes it
artificially easy to treat him as an
alien
one of the reasons i the author
gravitate to the study of ancient ethics
is precisely that it is difficult to
entangle those authors
in contemporary power struggles so i owe
callard an apology and this is a
correction
uh that she you know she uh like telep
is pointing out
the you know the the retrospective
bigotry
in looking to past historical figures
and finding
fault with their with their morals
rather than learning from them
um and understanding the space and time
in which they lived
all right so she does not want us to
cancel aristotle
which is in some ways unfortunately
she'd rather not cancel her
well right okay let's agree we won't
cancel her but the thing about
presumably canceling aristotle is
that uh we'd be in good shape if we were
warranted to do so because he will not
see it coming
he won't this is true oh easy target
which is part of the reason
retrospective bigoteering works
it's so effective yes yes yeah yeah
all right all right um i think we've
come to the end of this
hour yes we have come to the end of this
hour so we will be taking the superchat
questions that you
wrote in this hour as many as we can and
the ones that come in next hour
in starting in about 15 minutes you can
join us on our patreons where you'll
find discord and
private q a and there's a clips channel
that you can find some clips at
and various other goodies i guess your
your um
your second patreon private conversation
is tomorrow yeah for the motion
discussion
is going to be sunday at 10 o'clock
pacific time
very much looking forward to it today's
discussion on the coalition of the
reasonable
was excellent we got somewhere very good
i'm very
eager to continue that conversation next
month
if i can ask you all a favor i'm going
to
tweet the animation that we played at
the beginning of this
live stream and if you want to do
something to fight the power
to uh usher the empty shirts off the
stage so we can get some real leadership
you might consider retweeting or
otherwise broadcasting that animation
empty shirts sure but decrepit clowns
really makes the point more
vividly i am trying to be nicer dude
clown is something i say internally i
don't vocalize it as much anymore but
not very much yeah it is
it is still i'll do it for you okay i
appreciate that
okay well we will see you all in about
15 minutes like subscribe
notify those sorts of things and in the
meantime be well